what is the difference between a
dependent and an independent sample and
why is it important to know the
difference if you want to know the
answers you're at the right place in
order to check out the topics of all our
videos just visit datadept.net
there you will find explanations of all
our video topics
okay so let's get started with a simple
example
let's say you want to find out if
vacations have an influence on the
stress level of people
in order to do this you have created a
small online questionnaire on
datatab.net
which helps you to measure the stress
level of people
by using this questionnaire you ask
people before and after their vacation
about their stress level
now there are two possibilities
possibility one is you ask people before
they go on vacation
and then you ask other people
after they come back from vacation in
this case you would have an independent
sample
because the people you interviewed
before the vacation have nothing to do
with the people you interviewed after
the vacation the second possibility and
also the better one is
you interview people before they go on
vacation
and then you ask the same people again
after they return from devocation
in this case you would have a dependent
sample so the measured values are always
available in pairs
therefore if the people have nothing to
do with each other you have an
independent sample if the people you ask
before and after are the same and you
therefore have pairs
you call it a dependent sample so this
means you always have a dependent sample
if you interview one and the same person
at two points in time for example once
before a certain event at once after a
certain event has happened when we talk
about dependent samples the measured
values are always in pairs
the pairs for example result from
measurement repetitions with the same
person of course it's not necessary that
it's always a before and after
relationship that you want to study
a dependent sample also exists for
example
if you want to test whether a new type
of baseball bat has an influence on the
result of a baseball game
and you let the same people play once
with the old and ones with the new bet
in this case the measured values are
always available in pairs so each player
has used both bets and therefore there
are two measured values for each player
another example would be if you want to
find out whether in a couple
women for example do more gardening than
men do and you would also have dependent
samples in this case there would be two
measures at the time
but always in pairs and always one woman
and one man
further of course it doesn't even have
to be about people you could also
investigate whether lubricant has an
influence on the downtime of machines
then you would have measured values from
the machines with the old and then again
with the new lubricant which would also
be available in pairs but enough about
dependent samples now let's move on to
independent samples
in the case of independent samples
the values come from two or more
different groups for example if you ask
a group of men and a group of women
about their income we have independent
samples in this case a person from
sample one cannot be assigned to a
person from the other sample
in the case of independent and dependent
samples it's of course also possible
that there are more than two groups or
samples the important thing is that in
the case of an independent sample the
individual groups or samples have
nothing to do with each other
and in the case of dependent sample one
respondent occurs in all groups
depending on whether your data comes
from a dependent or an independent
sample
you need to use different hypothesis
tests if your data are independent for
example an independent samples t-test or
an analysis of variance without repeated
measures is used if your data are
dependent for example a t-test for
dependent samples or an analysis of
variance with repeated measures is used
but don't worry about that data that
will help you to find the right
hypothesis test and i'll show you how to
do it right now
just visit datadeb.net and copy your
data into this table
and click on this tab
let's say you've asked people in a
questionnaire about salary gender and
location
now you won't investigate whether gender
has an influence on the salary of people
then you simply click on salary and
gender and the t test for independent
samples is automatically calculated you
get the results nicely displayed and the
great thing is that data dep even helps
you with the interpretations
if the conditions are not met
you can also calculate the man with u
test with data tab
if you click on salary and location an
analysis of variance is automatically
calculated
but what if you have a dependent sample
you just copy the data into data tab
let's say your variables are called
before and after then when you click on
the variable before and after
you will automatically get the results
of a t-test for dependent samples
how does datadeb know that it is a
dependent sample
usually a row in the sample is a person
and if you now select two matric
variables data depth assumes that this
is a dependent sample
if this is not the case
you only need to click here
and the test for independent samples
will be calculated
i hope you enjoyed the video if you like
just try out datadeb it's very easy to
use bye and see you next time